nos preguntan cuál es la tasa de cambio
promedio de la función f que es esta
función en el intervalo menos 23 es un
intervalo cerrado porque está entre
estos paréntesis cuadrados en lugar de
paréntesis regulares por lo que incluye
ambos límites pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta vamos a
resolverlo juntos hay un par de formas
de conceptualizar la tasa de cambio
promedio de una función una forma de
pensar en ello es el cambio del valor de
la función dividido entre el cambio en x
es decir el cambio en el valor de la
función por x en promedio o sea el
cambio en el valor de la función
dividido entre el cambio en x y xi
decimos que es igual a fx también
podemos expresarlo como el cambio en g
entre el cambio en x en promedio cuando
cambia la función de acuerdo al cambio
unitario de x en promedio podemos
resolver esto con una tabla o tratar de
conceptualizar visualmente
primero vamos a resolverlo con la tabla
y después conectaremos los puntos
visualmente
aquí tenemos equis y acá tenemos de
igual a fx cuando x es igual a menos 2 a
que será igual a que es igual
efe de menos 2 que es igual a efe de
menos 2 que es igual a menos 8 que es
menos 2 a la tercera potencia menos 4
por 2 negativo por lo que es menos 8
negativo es decir más 8 lo que es igual
a 0 y cuando x es igual a 3 evaluamos el
otro extremo del intervalo ahora ya es
igual a efe de 3 que es igual a 27 que
es 3 a la tercera potencia menos 4 por 3
es menos 12
todo esto es igual a 15 cuál es el
cambio entre el cambio en x en este
intervalo la aie pasó de 0 a 15 por lo
que hay un incremento positivo de 15 en
g y cuál fue el cambio en x paso de
menos 2 a 3 positivos por lo
el cambio en x 5 positivo el cambio en x
es más 5 así que la tasa de cambio
promedio de g con respecto a x o la tasa
de cambio promedio de la función con
respecto a x en este intervalo es igual
a 3 si quieren pensar en esto
visualmente voy a tratar de dibujarlo
este es el eje x este es el eje y y la
función se comporta más o menos así
cuando x es igual a menos 2 f x es 0
luego sube y después baja y luego hace
esto también de este otro lado el
intervalo de interés va desde menos 2 a
3 como le estoy indicando acá esto es x
igual a menos 2 a x igual a 3 y lo que
queremos hacer es que del lado izquierdo
del intervalo la función es igual a cero
como vemos en este punto que estoy
dibujando en otro color y en el lado
derecho del intervalo f de 3 es igual a
15 que está por acá arriba permítanme
conectar un poco
mejor la función así que cuando pensamos
en la tasa de cambio promedio en este
intervalo simplemente nos referimos a la
pendiente de la recta que conecta estos
dos puntos la recta que conecta estos
dos puntos se ve más o menos así y
estamos calculando el cambio en y qué es
esto y vemos que el valor de la función
incrementa en 15 dividido entre el
cambio en x qué es esto de acá y cómo
pasamos de menos 2 hasta 3 el cambio en
x es de 5 esto es lo que hacemos cuando
pensamos en la tasa de cambio promedio